I think I nailed that let's see if I'm
memorable I say I am let's see what this
[ __ ] website has to say do you like
chips love chips open and eat them
without making a sound
my Alavi news tools
that's pretty quiet I thought I'm be s
take a memorable selfie and I think I've
got an idea
thinking ball pit I like can fit in here
got furniture here this is a perfectly
good tripod Oh God
god I can't even see what the [ __ ] is
happening god I can do it
lift up your eyebrows a little bit I
think I D like duck lips right so go
with the eyelids a little bit no just
try to get like a good angle you just
looked up your face and then I'm gonna
do my best kylo Ren like that looks
really good oh man so you're like the
go-to penis emoji that's excellent
is that weird cuz you're I'm I'm a woman
I mean no it's cool I wouldn't mind
being used in a conversation about
eggplant parmesan every now and again
but you know I'm just happy to be in the
mix yeah I guess I don't mind being used
for sexting either people use you to
sext yeah me and the speech bubble we're
talking dirty why what were you thinking
it's really not important you like a
weird poop sex thing come on what do you
want me to think you are literally a
poop okay that's fair
computing I think I'm probably already
pretty low well what the [ __ ] Oh point
seven five one that a good one
memorability hi whoa awesome 0.855 whoa
score point seven five I just got a
score of point eight eight I have a lot
of selfies on here don't look says it's
a very high I got a point nine seven
four they think that website is
completely accurate now considering that
I'm super memorable
you